It.
Welcome, Director. And the floor is yours. Thank you.
I feel really short. Okay.
I know. Good afternoon. I'm here to present the FY 23
budget proposal for the Administration and Regulatory Affairs
Department. With me is Val Barry, the CFO for our
department. Next slide, please.
Ara has 18 separate business units.
We're a composite of multiple functional areas
across the city that didn't fit into a single type of department.
And so we have this spread across ten divisions spread across
four different funds. And so we're here to talk about that today.
This slide shows our general fund division.
We have several of our ads and our deputy director
here. The divisions are listed on this slide. The Director's office.
Obviously. Sustainability and Resilience, which is Deputy Director
Priya Zechariah, who is here? Franchise administration.
Valerie Barry, regulatory permitting. Catherine Bruning.
Payroll Services is Karen Davidson, who could not be here today because her husband's
in the hospital. Operations in three one one, which is
Charles Jackson, and Financial Services, which is also Valerie
Berry. One of the things that I want to note before we
leave this slide is I'd like you to draw your attention to the number
that you see before you as our proposed FY 23 budget
of 32.174 million, we round that to 32.2.
However, 10.8 million of that amount is the transfer to the Bark
Special Fund from the general fund. So our actual budget
for the general fund is $21.4 million. Next slide,
please. So the previous slide showed
you our general fund operations. This slide, as well as the next three will
represent the organization charts for the special funds and the Central Services
Revolving Fund that we manage. On this slide, we show the budget
and division breakout for the Park Houston Special Fund.
Park Houston is led by Maria Urshad
and they manage all of the city's on street parking inventory.
Next slide, please.
Bark is the city's animal shelter. It is funded through the Bark
Special Revenue Fund. And it's led by Greg Damienoff,
assistant director, who is also here. The Bark Operational Division
includes six sections that administer all of the programs and services that
we provide for Houston's pets and pet owners. Next slide, please.
The property and casualty fund is a revolving fund where Ara's
risk management division is funded. Risk Management is led by Tina Paquette,
Assistant Director who is also here today. Risk Management handles all
of the commercial insurance for the city of Houston. Next slide,
please. The Central Services revolving
fund is a chargeback fund. You've heard from many of the directors here today
that they run services through the revolving fund. We do as well.
There's no FTEs assigned to this because those are reflected in
other places throughout our budget.
But this is where the costs for the citywide mailroom, the citywide print
shop, citywide payroll services and employee transit are flowed
through. Next slide, please. And these
are the categories of service that Arie provides and the statutory
mandates that require us to provide those services. Next slide,
please. And these are the penalties for failure
to provide the mandated services. Because Ara is
primarily a regulatory department, the majority of our services are
mandated by either federal, state or local ordinances.
And the penalties for nondelvery of those services can be anything from
substantial financial penalties as they are for payroll to even
criminal penalties. Next slide, please.
This slide summarizes our general fund revenues as
well as our special fund revenues. As you can see,
our estimated General Fund revenues for FY 23 will be down
by $1.9 million compared to year end FY 22,
primarily due to franchise fee decreases. As you can see from this slide,
the biggest single loss will be telephone franchise fees.
And these will continue to drop every year because they're based on the number of
landlines in Houston. And most of us don't use landlines
anymore. We also had a drop in our permitting revenues.
This is mainly from alcohol licenses and taxicab permits.
One bright spot in our revenue picture, even though it's small,
is a source of revenues called Das facilities or network nodes.
With the expansion of 5G, this source of revenue
is actually going up. It produces currently about $2 million a year. There is a
52% growth in this that's projected for FY 23.
We also administer two special funds the Bark Special
Revenue and the Park Houston Special Revenue Fund. As you can
see, we don't expect much growth in the Bark Special Revenue Fund. This is
primarily not an area that produces revenues. The little bit that
we do produce is in adoption fees, license fees and
wellness services. And because it is so hard to find veterinarians
these days, we had another resignation today. It is very difficult to
provide these services. So our revenues are not expected to come back up in FY
23 for parking. However, we do
have a better story. Post pandemic. Houstonians are
getting back out. They're starting to park in all of our inner city areas and
they're using parking meters. So this year they're projected to increase by about
7% or 1.3 million. We're also
projecting increases in the revolving funds. Now remember, these are not revenues.
These are just paying back the general Fund for costs. So what you see there
in the $1.7 million increase from FY 22 to
FY 23 is the 10% increase in the property
insurance premiums for the City of Houston. Next slide, please.
On the previous slide, I showed you all of the individual categories of
general fund revenues and the anticipated decline for FY 23. So I
won't go into a lot of detail on this one because this just provides the
narrative for everything that I just said. But I do want to highlight three
things. First is electricity Revenues CenterPoint remains the
highest source of revenues to the City of Houston, paying us $95 million a year
for the use of our streets. Telephone franchise fees are the second
highest fee that we collect. And as I said, this is a rapidly
disappearing source of franchise fees. At one point it was $60 million.
It's down to $17 million. We can count on that decreasing every
budget year when I'm here. And cable TV franchise fees also are
disappearing because many of us are using Netflix and Hulu and prime,
and we're not using cable TV anymore. So that is also a rapidly disappearing
source of revenue. So the takeaway from this slide is that
between decreasing telephone and cable franchise fees, you're losing almost $30
million. And that accounts for $30 million in the general fund
budget. Next year. You can expect that to be much lower.
The next slide, please. On this slide we talk about
more detail related to revenues. Permanent and license revenues, as I
said, had gone down because alcohol establishments were closed during the pandemic.
And that's where we get many of our fees as well as taxicab permits.
Taxicabs had already been decimated by the TNCs.
This pretty effectively eliminated the industry.
And as always, we do attempt to offset our revenue losses
through aggressive auditing and aggressive compliance efforts. This year,
we expect to collect $300,000 in delinquent
revenues just based on those audits. Next slide, please.
And just as I showed all of the funds that we administer on the revenue
slide, this slide summarizes the expenditures for all of
the funds that are administered by Ara. I highlighted
in yellow the row with the general fund expenditures since I know that's what
you're most interested in. And in a few minutes, when we get to the
net change slide, I'll actually walk you through in detailed that
revenue increase of 1.34 million. But for now, we're going to
talk about the special funds. First up is Park Houston.
The increase in expenditures that you see here is based on
two sources. The first is the addition of FTEs for a new
planned fourth shift for compliance. The second
is an increase in the transfer of revenue to the general fund.
As I said before, we didn't have people parking during the pandemic,
so the transfer to the general fund was much smaller. For FY 23,
we were projecting to transfer $5.5 million from the parking
special revenue fund to the general fund, an increase of $2 million
over what we were able to do this year. The next special fund is Bark.
Bark is the opposite of park. Houston. Rather than transferring money to
the general fund, bark receives money from the general fund.
For FY 23, they'll be receiving 10.8 million. For FY 22,
it was 10.5 million. And finally, in the property casualty
fund, you see the increase there. Again, that's an increase in both revenues
and expenditures. It's a flow through fund. Next slide, please.
And this is the graphical representation of the proposed FY 23
general fund budget. As you can see, the biggest pieces of this
budget are personnel, which is 54% of the budget, or 17.3
million. The second biggest piece is the $10.8 million
transfer to BARC which is 34% of our total expenditure budget.
And then finally, the restricted accounts represent more than half of the 12%
that remains of Ara's General Fund expenditure budget. So only 1.6%
of our total $32.2 million FY 23 proposed budget
is what you might call discretionary meaning that it's not already obligated
to personnel or some sort of contractual or mandated obligation but it's
available for supplies and services. Next slide,
please. This is the same breakdown for the Bark
Special Revenue Fund. Bark's proposed budget is what?
13.3 million. And as I said before, the lion's share of that is the
$10.8 million transfer from the General Fund
in Bark. 67% is personnel expenses.
Next slide piece. And this is
the breakdown for the park houston Special Revenue Fund.
Personnel is 34% of the expenditures of this special revenue
fund. The other big piece of this is 26%
which is the transfer from the Park Houston Special Revenue Fund
to the General Fund. Next slide, please.
And this is the breakdown for Ara's portion of the Property Casualty
Service Fund. Again, this is where our risk management group is
funded. You'll notice that only 3% of this fund
goes to pay for personnel. 97% is insurance premiums
for the City of Houston. Next slide, please.
This is the more complicated slide. There's five blocks
here and we're going to walk through those as quickly as we can while giving
you the detail. Our current budget is broken
out. At the top block, you'll see $17.75 million.
That's our actual FY 22 operating budget.
These are the funds that are available for the General Fund operations of our department.
Added to that amount is the restricted accounts, totally 2.48
million. And then the General Fund transfer to Bark, which is 10.5
million in FY 22. So if you add the restricted items
for FY 22 plus the transfer to Bark, which was 10.5
the total operating budget that was not available to Ara and
FY 22 was $12.6 million leaving only
the 17.74 million for our operations.
The next block is called Adjustments to FY 22 budget.
These are the amounts that were added or taken out of our budget during the
current fiscal year. And so you have things like the contractual
hope, municipal pay raises and the amount of $283,000 for the General Fund
and $161,000 for Bark. A restricted
accounts adjustment of $71,000.
$21,000 received from Council member Cisneros's Budget Surplus
Fund to fund spay neuter efforts for Bark.
A $17,000 adjustment for scanning services related
to the records retention project at the City Secretary's office which Ara
is managing. And then the last item in the second block is a $117,000
increase for Bark shelter, cleaning and a rescue initiative. Those are explained in
footnote three. Altogether, these items yield a net increase from
our FY 22 budget of $527,000
bringing the FY 222 year end adjusted budget to
$30.83 million. And then in the next section, you see the
operating budget adjustments that get us to FY 23.
These are the amounts that are added to or reduced from the
FY 22 budget to get us here. So the $21,000.01 time
receipt from Council Member Cisneros from her budget surplus
would be subtracted out in FY 23. You'll also
see $216,000 of onetime funds from an FY
22 budget amendment, and the details of those are spelled out in footnote
five. And then in the third block, you also see $328,000
being added to fund various one time programs, including the three one
one hiring initiative. And then the details for the $328,000
are laid out for you in footnote four. And I'll also go through those in
just a second on the next slide. So when you net out the reductions and
the increases in that third block, we end up with a $91,000 net
increase to Ara's budget for specific programs for FY
23. Continuing down the page, we're now to the fourth block.
You see our contractual or mandated adjustments, and this includes
the increases for health benefits, hope, contractual pay raises,
municipal pension costs and restricted accounts. The total
is an increase of $1.25 million to the Ara
budget. And finally, in the fifth block, we arrive
at the proposed FY 23 budget of 32.174
million. And as you can see, the Ara General Fund budget is
increasing by 1.34 million. But of that amount,
only $91,000 is an actual increase to our operating budget.
Everything else is a contractual or mandated amount. At the bottom block,
you have the page that contains the footnotes that detail every adjustment I just discussed.
Next slide, please. And then this slide summarizes
the big picture expenditure changes that we discussed on the previous slide for the General
Fund, as well as the highlights of our special fund expenditures.
So in addition to the increases for health benefits, pension contribution and
municipal employee contractual pay increases across all funds,
let me reiterate into the general fund the adjustments that are being made are the
$36,000 in one time funding. For the City Secretary records
retention project, the $20,991 in
funding for a hiring incentive to recruit and retain new three
one one agents and $224,861
in resilience funding transferred from the Planning Department to
Ara for the Resilience and Sustainability Office. For the Bark
Special Fund, we received $256,000 for a shelter
cleaning contract, $30,000 for a rescue incentive
program, $39,000 for the Pep Microchipping Initiative,
and then a reduction of FY 22
non recurring program adjustments of $563,000.
And finally, for Park Houston, we received
program adjustments funding for ten additional employees to add a fourth
shift of compliance officers. And we realized after we published this
slide that there is an error on the Park Houston bullet. The amount
for the fourth shift is $280,000, and the slide shows
$256,402. Next slide,
please. This concludes our budget presentation
please note that our restricted accounts details, organization charts,
demographics and other relevant materials are included as appendices to this presentation,
including the top three one one service requests for each one of your council
districts. Thank you for your attention. Thank you,
Director. So,
just forward thinking some of your revenue
sources, like cable and television.
We're seeing reduced revenues coming in
because of less usage. So thinking about
the future, what are some creative ideas or ways in which you think we
can generate more revenue? Is there anything in the pipeline maybe discussed
at the state level that you can see that would generate more
revenue through fees? So at the state level,
they have continued to erode our fees. For example, when they took away
TNCs, that would have been a $70 million revenue by now.
Network nodes by now would have been $40
million revenue. But that was also decimated at the state level.
It's still a growing revenue, but by no means the size that it would have
been. And so what the mayor charged us with was finding
anything in the right of way that we were not charging fees for already,
because again, it belongs to the public and the public should be reimbursed for it.
And that's what we've tasked our group to do. We're speaking to public works
about what things that they are charging permitting fees for that should
actually be rental because the city charter does call for uses
in the right of way to be reimbursed as rental rather than permit
fees. Thank you, Council Member Amy Pick.
Thank you, Vice Chair. And thank you, Director, for the presentation.
Can you talk a little bit more about three one one and anything that
might be in the budget to fix the three one one app and
the three one system this next fiscal year? I'm very
glad you brought that up because we are completely expecting
that by the end of the year we'll have a new app. When we rolled
out the new three one one system, we were excited about it because it has
all kinds of really cool functionality if you're at your desktop.
And we thought that what most people wanted, based on the customer feedback
that we'd gotten, was to be able to figure out what the status of their
service request was. That was the single biggest complaint we got under the old
system. And when you use the old app, it changed the
number of your service request. By the time you got to
the actual system and went into the web to check it, everybody was angry about
that. So we thought what we're going to do instead is optimize the desktop
app for mobile and then everyone will have all the information they want. And what
we didn't realize was that what customers also wanted to do was take pictures
and be able to drop a GIS pin. So the new app
is going to have the best features of all of that. We're going back to
Cclick Fix, which was the app we used before, but we're enhancing it
now so that it has a lot of the neat functional features that we added
to the desktop app. And it will also include the neat things about
picture taking in GIS. And that will be out before the end of the year.
So how much money did we spend on going to
this new three one one app? And are we just out that money that we
spent transferring over and then going back? So the new app
was actually in the original development cost of the whole system. It wasn't
a separate cost. It actually was not something that was very
hard for Accenture to do because all that they did was optimize the
desktop app. So that wasn't a cost. And it's not a matter of recouping
that there is a cost to the new app that's coming up and there will
be a new contract that Hits will actually be bringing to you to approve
and vet. Okay, thank you.
Council member Abby Cayman. Hi,
Director. First off, to all of your
divisions. I don't know how Ara encompasses so
much. It's truly extraordinary. But my staff
just did a tour of three one one, and I cannot thank the
operators enough there. The retention, the knowledge that they have
is extraordinary. Bark I know that
times have been really challenging. I think you just mentioned we just lost
another veterinarian.
What are we trying to do to recruit right now other than financial
incentives for veterinarians? I know that has been an
issue even before coming into office, and I know I even
talked to veterinarian offices around the city,
or at least in my district. Same thing. It's hard right now.
What else are we looking at in terms of that right now?
It's a national shortage. So what we used to
do was regularly just go around the country and poach.
And now most veterinarians who are graduating do not
want to do shelter medicine. If they're going to do veterinary
medicine at all, they want to work in a private practice where they get to
use the cool new technology and do a lot of diagnostics spaying
and neutering. Not the most fun thing to do. So it's hard.
One of the things that we'd like to do is start an internship program with
one of the universities, and Council member Cisnero's led an effort toward that.
We haven't gotten much traction with A and M, honestly, but now
we're looking at going national with any other vet school that's willing to partner with
us. And we would find a way to pay for their interns that come here,
even if it's through private funding. But we're working with best friends and some
of our other partners locally to try to troubleshoot that. And I
appreciate the partnership with outside organizations. I also wanted to
give a huge shout out to parking.
Incredible job, especially dealing with a lot of the challenges that we face
inside the District and obviously the Office of Resiliency
and Sustainability, that's going to be monumental and historic
work that's taking place there. Two quick questions.
Three quick questions. One, scanning for all
of our records and archiving, is that really happening? That's really
happening. The mayor asked us last year or
the year before to go over to city secretary's office and at least start boxing
everything up to get it organized. And we did that, and she has been so
welcoming to us and working with us on that. And then he gave us money
to start the scanning project. We're actually working with the state of Texas.
They have someone who archives all of their records, and we're sending
up 100 boxes at a time to get them scanned and make them searchable.
Because remember, there's no point in having them just be PDFs. They need to be
searchable PDFs. Okay. And do we have a timeline,
estimated timeline for completion on that? The mayor wants it
done before he leaves. Okay, understood. Can I be
placed back in queue, please? You're back in the queue
now. All right,
director, one thing I wanted to bring up, and I'm happy
to talk offline about it, but last year council did pass
an amendment that I drafted related to and first off,
thank you to the department for all of the work on the sound ordinance changes
thus far. Sally is like, yes, huge victory.
There was one other thing we had asked the department to look at, which is
weekend hours as it relates to construction.
Right now, there's no distinction between weekday and weekends.
We're getting construction 07:00 a.m. Saturdays and
Sundays, and residents need a reprieve.
Again, we had set a timeline for the end of this fiscal year, and I
know it's coming up, so I just wanted to check on
the status of that. If you all are ready to proceed with stakeholder
meetings on that and what we can do. We have not even
begun that the changes to the noise ordinance that we made took so much longer
than anyone anticipated they were going to make with stakeholders that we put this
on the back burner because, remember, it was a whole different group of stakeholders than
restaurants and everyone else. So that's something I have to circle back with with the
mayor and ask him if we can now start having those stakeholder meetings for
that. Okay. If we could talk offline about that and just come up with kind
of a plan of attack, our residents would really
appreciate it. And then lastly, you've addressed a lot
of needs. Is there anything else that you want to mention to us
that we need to be aware of in terms of upcoming needs in the foreseeable
future, given how tight this budget is?
So you've been asking every department that question. So we
thought a lot about it. And the mayor has been very good about giving one
time money where it was needed. For example, for our hiring initiative for three one
one. By the way, our turnaround time right now, our average speed of
Anderson for three one one is consistently less than a minute. So you should be
very happy to hear that. But our biggest need is embark.
We can't keep people, we can't hire people. We consistently have
between a 20% to 35% vacancy in that division. And it's
not even an animal enforcement officers, believe it or not. We can keep those.
It's the people who clean the shelter every day. So the mayor
said, well, okay, if we don't have enough people to keep the shelter clean and
then also be able to feed and water and treat the animals, let's get
a cleaning contract in there and get some contractors in to clean it to free
up the employees. We did that and you see the money here for it.
The first week they showed up, they came with four people and three of them
left and said, this is not my gig. I'm not doing this. So we're still
troubleshooting that, but our single biggest need is people.
Understood? Thank you. And again, thank you to the there's a lot of people back
there. Thank you all for everything that you do.
Yeah, you want to have your team stand up in the back so we can
say hello and thank you.
Thank you all for everything that you do.
We know you make the most out of a little and we appreciate all
your efforts, all the engagement with our offices and look forward
to working with you in the days ahead. So thank you, Director and Ms.
Barry for your presentation. And you are dismissed. Thank you,
sir. We'll now move to the public comment period.
We'll start with the virtual public speakers. Please press star six
to unmute when you hear your name. First name is Amanda
she.
Hello. Thank you.
Does Ara or any other department do analysis
on the three one one calls to identify broad
or persistent gaps in service delivery?
That's a great question. I would like to know the answer to that
myself. We will respond to that question
within 48 hours. So if you want to, please send that over to District E
at houstontx Gov, we'll get a response for you.
Do you have any other questions, Ms. She?
No, I do not. Thank you. Thank you.
Saba Blanding. Hi.
I know staff has already been discussed. I was
just curious if there were any additional financial resources Bark
needed to address Houston's stray population.
I'm sure additional resources are greatly needed and
appreciated. Many of our offices use our council district service
funds to also put through projects to work with Bark and Houston Humane
Society for spay and neuter programs. So if you want to reach
out to your district council member on ways in which to
understand the money that they may be allocating or any of the eleven
district council members. We'll be able to provide that information to you. But pretty regularly
around the city of Houston, the District council members are putting
forth spay and neuter programs for the public to
take notice of and be a part of.
Thank you. You're welcome. Jason Oliver.
My first question follows up on Amanda.
I definitely am interested in the three one one analysis.
I'd also like to know about what other performance measures Ara has
for three one one call. Answering time is important and
as it shows, there's major room for improvement.
But I'd also like to know just see more metrics around the service,
around service delivery. And then second harkening
back to fleet management metrics. The city consistently
uses around 10 million gallons of fuel every year.
Where does fuel reduction show up in the city's sustainability plans?
And how are we doing with that?
Council Member David Robinson. Mr. Oliver, another great question from
you about our fuel goals.
That the reduction of our
reliance on both petroleum gas products
is in both our Climate Action Plan as well as
the Resilient Houston plan. The exact section and reference
and goals are outlined in that.
So I again commend you for the good question.
We can help you locate that if you're unaware of that or
otherwise get an update for you about the current status of
attaining those goals. Thanks for the question.
Thank you. I'll check the reports and see what we've
got. There are no additional public speakers.
And this concludes our Administrative and Regulatory Affairs budget workshop.
We will now move to begin our budget workshop
for municipal courts. I believe
that we had other speakers in the audience who
signed up. They were on the list emailed to us.
Good catch.
Our first in person public speaker is Meredith
Powell. Meredith Powell.
Luckily, Amy recognizes me.
Thank you. Ms. Powell, the floor is yours. Thank you. Good afternoon,
council members. My name is Meredith Powell. I live in district a
by profession. I'm a communications and community relations consultant.
I'm also the president of my neighborhood association, so Council member Peck
and her staff hear from me regularly.
I'm very passionate about animal welfare issues and I
recognize the role for Bark. I'm not one of those people who's like Bark
is bad and all of that kind of stuff. I'm here to encourage
you all, whether it is within your own districts or
as a council, to increase resources as much as possible
for Bark. Because thousands
of animals live on the street and need rescuing. And while there are many rescue
groups and street rescuers like myself, we can only do
so much. I work with Rpm and straight out of Texas to transport
animals as much as possible. But I encourage you to give as many resources
to Bark. Because if we don't give resources to Bark and animal. Control.
It just exacerbates the problem that we're having because we have stray
animals on the street that are not fixed. And it's just creating even
more of a population that we're dealing with.
So one of the things I wanted to raise is
when we do the transport rescues, many of the people in other states ask,
what is the problem with Houston? What is the city doing about it?
And it makes us look really bad. I mean, Houston's leader in energy,
space exploration, health care, all of these different things.
Yet we get questions about what is the leadership position that
Houston is taking to deal with the animal welfare issues.
So I know we're working on microchip laws and I
applaud city council and the city of doing those kind of things and stray and
neuter efforts. I just encourage you to continue to provide resources to
Bark to address our city's ongoing animal issue.
Thank you. Are there some specific areas within Bark
that you think the dollars would be most best utilized for? I mean,
sometimes I see programs that I don't think make sense. I understand when
we want to offer adoptions at low rates, but we also have
to ensure that people who adopt at lower cost have the resources
to pay for the animals, because then what happens is animal turnins
or they release them as strays. So that's an issue. I think there's
an opportunity for better public private partnership. We do
so much with our theater district and sports and all of these areas where we
have these huge companies who are supporting our efforts within the
city. We don't really see that within Bark and animal control. I think that that's
an opportunity. Great suggestion.
Council member Amy Peck. Thank you, Meredith, for speaking today.
And I just wanted to thank you for all the work that you do,
especially in District A, when it comes to the animal population.
She is constantly out there rescuing stray
pets and doing so much work. So I just wanted to thank you for that
and for coming today. Thank you. Council Member Abby Cayman
I also just wanted to thank you for your efforts with Rescued Pets movement.
I know we've partnered in our office with them in the efforts.
My mom's even volunteering now. Really just
amazing and beautiful work. I think your point about public private
partnerships is dead on. And even including I
was thinking, especially with the veterinarian shortage, how do we tap
into the vet services that we already have in the city and that infrastructure and
getting volunteers and things like that. So all that's
to say, thank you. I really appreciate it. And I know
Council Member Peck really respects and appreciates all the work that you do in the
district. Thank you. And I encourage you to continue to reach out
to Council Member Peck and any of us if you have any specific
ideas. I know as the presentation was stated, that the
mayor has a commitment to sometimes put one time funding sources
towards specific needs with bark. And they still sometimes have
challenges with recruitment, with retaining and with getting some of
the services done. But any ideas? A person like yourself
who has vast experience and understanding of the infrastructure
of that entity would be greatly appreciated. Thank you so
much. You're welcome.
Are there any in person public speakers who
would like to come forward?
Well, now, this concludes our Administrative and Regulatory
Affairs budget workshop.